裙子来看下这一款新款一个藏蓝色半身裙
后半边松紧有拉链隐形拉链这一条藏蓝色藏蓝色的
来腰尾腰尾62 62 72
6272群长75这个39扣5藏蓝色的这一条
39块扣5扣5
这4个那个啥别4个高货了
有我看看4条36S这个牌子
这个牌子的4个高货
来扣5扣5 39块扣个5
39扣个5
来这一条
是一个黑色的
黑色的一条半身裙
就像空气棉一样特别垂面量很软
而且面量是有弹力的
后半边松紧腰尾68 94
68 94腿尾112 130群长90
群长90这个39扣1扣1
39块扣个1
39 39扣1扣1
39块钱扣个1
来这个纱裙
这个纱裙里面有一层内衬
内衬可以取下来的
内衬给你拿下来
就这样的一个纱裙
有米色有灰色
这个是黑色三个颜色一共是
来腰尾看一下
腰尾66到88的腰
66到88群长
群长是88群长88
这个29块扣个8
2929扣8扣8的一条
纱裙纱裙
29块扣8扣8
29扣个8
叠点水
哎呦
我这没那么早
人呢
咋不聊天了
来这个紫色
这个明明留了一件
紫色的一条半身裙摆着的
摆着摆着
单层没有内衬
面料很薄很薄
这样子
来这个腰尾
腰尾的话是66到92
66 92
裙长86
这个有要的39块
哭6哭6
紫色紫色的一条半身裙
39 39
哭6哭6这一条
39块
哭个6哭个6
紫色面料很垂
而且这个面料很柔软
好舒服的这种
来这个39块
哭6哭6
39哭个6
哭个6
39块
来这个
背带裙
这个是前面吧
这个是前面
哪个是前面
哪个是
这个是前面
这个是后面
应该是两面都能穿
我感觉这个
是不是两面都能穿
这一款前面有口袋
不对前面有个大拉链
然后这个不好
这个上面刮伤了呢
刮了个洞呢
刮了一个小洞呢
但里面还有一层
这个里面还有一层
正好有一层
这个这一截
给它挡住了
看到没
拿着一个袋子
袋子可以调节
来胸围
胸围是94到96
94 96的胸围
来这个裙长
裙长是118
长短可以调节
9块钱
有个洞洞
我的妈呀
这39
39的
给你给你炸了
来吧
小黄油
炸了炸了
不能写炸
不能写个洞
6块有个大洞
来吧来吧
人少
人多了
这个最少不行的
刘老板抓到我
等会儿
我来给你讲一下
还有其他的想要吃过
okok
其他没有了
,谢谢谢谢
哎这有个毛泥大一
你们之前挂后面的
你们俩个粉色也有瑕疵
之前挂后面的粉色
就这个款吗
这个款我咋没见过粉色的
来这个i k k a的一个大一
毛泥大一毛泥大一点冒了这一块
然后前面是有一个大拉链
肉粉色的肉粉色的
来这个胸围
胸围的话是104106
来这个长度长度83
长度83
那个有瑕疵正好
这个也有瑕疵
直接9块钱给你了
来这个39块扣3扣3
原价是69的这一块
39给你们扣3扣3毛泥黑色
这个是放59的
来这个39块了
扣3扣3
i k k a的
这个还有吊牌
这个9800的吊牌价呢
m嘛
9800的一个吊牌价
看见没
9800的吊牌价呢
来这个39块
39块扣8
放在这个后面
39扣个8
好的
没有了
哎呀
来这个黑色
黑色毛泥的一个背心裙
春秋冬可以穿这一件
这有三个颜色
好像原来有个米色
还有一个卡鞋
这个是个黑色的
这出来一个黑色
迪亚是迪亚是那个鱼尾的
鱼尾的两边有直插口袋
这一条后面是有隐形拉链
这个是宣解包色的
胸围92112
92112胸围
来这个长度
长度是95
长度95
这个29扣5
29块扣5扣5
扣5
这个也属于高货的呢
和那个QU11的那个半裙是一起来货的
这个原来卖59的
29块扣5扣5
这个不知道是啥牌子
没有标
29块扣个5
春秋冬可以穿
毛泥的这种
扮相很好
29块扣5扣5
29块扣个5
来这个
这个是藏蓝色的一个裙
这个好大
后面开叉这样的一个
后面开叉都好长又长又大来这个
腰上是有腰带
后面可以绑一下子有大腰带
胸围
胸围是130134
来这个长度
长度127
这个咱没有腰的空隙
我后面开叉的
这个有要的29
扣1扣1
29块扣个1扣个1
藏蓝色的一个裙
还有个大腰带了
29扣1扣1
29块
来这个工装裤
黑色一条工装裤
黑色的一条工装裤
这是啥牌子
俩油的
巨指78
人民18
居然指4
这个牌子
来
后半边松拧的
腰围76
腿围
腿围是120130
当长40
裤长97
裤腿底下是有这个松拧
可以收的
可以收的呢
这个裤腿工装裤
这个
扣2
39块
扣2扣2的一条
裤腿底下可以收腿
39块
扣2扣2
39扣个2
这个这个裙刚过到一个
蕾丝的这个裙
我就不量尺寸了
19块了
现在放福利
扣2扣2
扣个2
19块
扣2扣2
这个
摸满了一个圈
19块
扣个2
mik1的
mik1的这个小碎花
看看
mik1的一个小碎花
这个中长款的一个上衣
啊
前扣的话是一个微领
后面是一个小纽扣
这一款腰上有腰带
腰带不少
这个来胸围
胸围的话是104120
来这个长度
长度是80
长度80
这个有要的扣59扣5扣5
59扣个5
来买可以的
59 59
扣5扣5
59块扣5扣5
来买可以的这个
L是吗
花型好看的
里面
嗯
腰带也不少
59扣个5
59块扣个5
哦
来这个蓝灰色一个牛仔
后面是有一个刺绣小小美女的呢
小美女的呢
这个是
均码
绵40
聚质31
人绵20
再生纤维3
尼龙2
晴轮2
这一条灰色
灰色一条直筒的
来这个腰围
腰围62
腿围1102
当长38
裤长102
来这个咱们有腰的扣
这个有腰的39扣8
39块
扣8扣8这一条
直筒直筒的呀
39块
扣8扣8
灰色一条牛仔
这个上面是有一个刺绣小美女的
39块
扣8扣8
39扣个8扣个8
39扣个8
这一条哇
这个面料舒服
又垂
又凉快
薄的很
看看
这个薄的很
两边有写啥口袋的
这个裤子
超级好
全松紧的
来腰围
腰围的话是68
68能拿是106了
腿围120132
三长41
裤长是100
这个39扣1呀
哇
这个面料挺舒服
39块
扣1扣1
两边有口袋
你看看
超舒服
这条裤
扣1扣1